[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table
the dim lighting we're picking up where
we left off last week and in
illuminating the dark years the last
year they're not dark yeah the last year
yes so this have rhettandlink part two
of us filling in a big gap in our lives
that we have never really talked about
and that is really the you know the
breath of our college experience and
then especially which is what we're
gonna get into this week what happened
after we graduated and how did we go
from graduating working as engineers and
then eventually becoming youtubers and
it's not the path that you would expect
or you have heard in interviews or
articles that you have read about us if
you haven't listened to last week's
podcast then you definitely need to do
that yeah come on listen do not listen
to this one without going back to part
one but I will just quickly sort of
catch us up to where we're at and can I
say before you do that that to reiterate
that the plan is there's so many this is
so logistical in terms of connecting the
dots of our careers professionally but
there's an entire personal and spiritual
aspect to the story that we're saving
that side of the coin for each of us for
the next two episodes we're each going
to take we'll both be there but we'll
each take an episode to share our own
stories of our spiritual journeys which
which go through the times that we're
talking here as well as bringing us up
to where we are now so that will be the
next two episodes hashtag ear biscuits
with any thoughts comments questions you
have about anything we're talking about
today we're accumulating those so that
when we're through those next two
episodes then we can be a part of that
conversation at that point yeah so to
recap what we covered last week we
talked about the fact that you know when
we started our careers we grew up as
evangelical Christians
and that is not how we would describe
ourselves now and like link said we'll
talk about that whole process and why we
would not call ourselves that now in
subsequent individual podcasts but
because it played such a integral role
in who we were and then every decision
that we made professionally as you're
about to hear we wanted to kind of fill
in the gaps so we got last week we got
from high school through college talked
about our very very heavy involvement in
Campus Crusade for Christ and how that
was really the first opportunity we ever
had to be comedians that was when we
started being rhett and Link on stage in
front of a group of people yeah
though the weekly meeting NC State and
then every Christmas at the Christmas
conference / winter conference where
multiple states would come together
cruise students and you and then both of
us would start em seeing that so when we
graduated it was you know it was it was
a kind of a it was a point of decision
because you know our lives for the past
four plus years had been so much of our
life experience had been wrapped up in
our involvement in Campus Crusade for
Christ that not only was it daunting to
just graduate and move into the real
world so to speak but also to there was
an imply that we were leaving behind
such a big part of our experience
specifically being involved in Campus
Crusade and being involved visibly so
much and our passion is being so engaged
there so now it's like okay I'd been
working at IBM for in a coop on and off
so while you were in school you were
like taking semesters and working but I
got a job with IBM you got a job as a
civil and well back up just a second
because while I was in college in fact I
remember going into my senior year
mm-hmm our involvement in Campus Crusade
and then specifically I took two summer
project trips I took one in New York
City
in 98 and then I took one to Slovakia in
99 and again the way I've always
described what I did in Slovakia because
it's not untrue is teaching English but
the reality was it was English camps you
know teaching English with the intention
of teaching people about Christianity
that's kind of that's kind of how these
organizations work it's like you know
you you you kind of go into a situation
under a certain pretense but ultimately
what you're after is communicating the
conversion and convert converting people
to Christianity and that doesn't mean
that the experiences were not incredibly
fruitful at least for me personally and
enriching and getting to travel and
experience people in other places that
were different than me same for me going
to Santa Cruz and being in a amusement
park ride operator right and so we told
stories from those periods of times but
we never really explained why we were
there that was why we were there but
that experience especially my experience
in Slovakia in getting to know people
who had basically given their lives
vocationally like professionally to to
crew to work full-time and seeing that
these people are just like man they're
happy they're happy to wake up in the
morning this is during they're engaged
they are engaged very closely with what
they're doing they're continuing the
from our vantage point the experience
that we were having and so aligned with
in college professionally well and I
think the thing that ends up happening
and this is this isn't just true of
people who get involved in religious
organizations but again you're so
passionate and you usually kind of find
your cause and the thing that you're
into in your early 20s and then what you
begin to see is you begin to look around
at the adults in your life and you're
like what is wrong with you guys you're
all dead you don't you I remember going
back to my local church having been
involved in Campus Crusade and gone to
these weekly meetings and gone to these
conferences where we were worshiping and
we were you know singing these
and I was being filled with the spirit
overwhelmed emotional experiences and
then you go back to your church and
you're like got what it just matter to
you guys and you become sort of a
disillusioned you know you think that
you've got to figure it out and you
think that the adults that have just
lost it but when you find these people
who have decided to go on staff they
seem passionately engaged with exactly
the stuff that you're currently
passionately engaged with so at that
point I made the decision this is what I
want to do I want to go on staff I want
to be full-time staff of Campus Crusade
I well you made the decision yeah I went
home I'll come to you I may not remember
this but I went home after that trip and
I told my parents I was like I don't
want to get an engineering degree I just
don't I want to get a communications
degree I'd like to take these last two
to three semesters okay I remember and
transfer into communications because
this is what I'm good at you know I do
I'm a good speaker
I want to be I want to learn more about
that and also I just kind of want to get
more involved in ministry I'll have more
time if I'm in communications than
engineering because it's let's be honest
way easier and then my dad actually said
he was like you know what because my
brother had already gone on staff so my
brother Cole was on staff with Campus
Crusade at the time we're all ready I
think he started at UNC I think that's
where he was and so it was already in
the family you know again cold plate we
talked about coal a lot like he sube we
listened to our very first hip-hop
because of because of cold a lot of
other things he blazed a trail the older
brother we were comfortable following
but if he had never gotten involved
Campus Crusade we also would not be here
I believe you know it's a domino effect
so it would have been an inner varsity
himhe right he was we'd were in we got
something we skipped over shout-out to
inner varsity we were and we flirted
with y'all we were in an interval Bible
study as well as a crusade Bible stay
hey y'all heard to Bible study to pace
ourselves enough Bible studies y'all so
we ended up I ended up thinking I was
gonna go on staff because Cole was
already on staff and
but my dad was like you know I think it
would be great if you go on staff but
you've got to more basic you got one
more year of engineering school yeah to
just have an engineering degree and I
think it would be it would serve you
better in the long run you can do all
the things that you want to do it does
an engineering degree but you'll have an
engineering all you wanted was a little
more fun yeah I was playing twisted
metal with Greg all the time I was
having such a good time so I thought
that was reasonable and I'm actually
glad that my dad told me that because I
feel a little bit cooler than I can say
I have an engineering degree it's just a
[ __ ] that's all it is
but then when you did graduate when I
graduated I immediately got married and
I took a job with IBM you know I felt
like I was much more pulled to that
responsible decision and I had a find
the financial security of the job that
they offered was something that oh gosh
I just couldn't I couldn't walk away
from that but but I did have I did still
have that pull to all of the things that
you described and I would add to that
that the the way that we were able to
engage with an audience and with
Christmas conference every year like as
we talked about last week our passions
were so aligned to like pour so much of
any of our free time into that it was
like I just also didn't want to I didn't
want to give that up or I I knew that I
would miss that just as much as anything
it was the most it was a passion like
entertaining a crowd well it was also a
marine for us and we there were the
expectation was that we would continue
him seeing the conference I don't
remember what the conversation was but
it was an open invitation and we knew we
wanted to do that so but we do pretty
much covers but but you decided to also
take a job as a ninja the reason being I
fell in love with my wife Jessie who was
still a student that's where we got
married this summer after her sophomore
year in college you cradle-robber
and you can't go on staff with a wife
that's in Kyle
with a child and so I was like okay I'm
gonna use this engineering degree I'm
welcome try this out for a little bit
she's got a she actually finished school
in like three she got the double major
in like three and a half years at
Carolina which somehow she did that
while married to me but but anyway but
we agreed to can you agreed to continue
to be the host of the Christmas
conference every year and at some point
maybe now maybe a year or so later like
I would be like a co MC but right from
the beginning I was there with you us
working together on a volunteer basis
not as official staff but as volunteers
to show up to take our vacation to to
store up our vacation from our
engineering jobs and then below most of
it you know December 26th through then
but and then so then I remember months
leading up to the end of the year and
the conference we would get together
every single week I would I would drive
from from my house and apex to the edge
of campus at Carolina where Jessi was
still going to school and you guys had
the house and every week we'd get
together and we plan for months and
months leading up to this thing it was
our one opportunity to still have that
audience yeah and to come up with stuff
so we'd write songs we come up with
video concepts we figure out the
sketches and stuff that we were gonna do
crowd interaction stuff on stage yes it
was all very very very meticulously
planned and also there's a lot of
anxiety like I was having a great time
but I just remember hmm it's funny in
light of how much content we put out
there now and how many things that we
get ready forward and all of a sudden do
I remember just being so stressed out
about Christmas cards like enjoying it
but like so stressed out about how it
was gonna go and it's funny how the same
way we are now no I'm saying yeah we're
right but uh it seems so like dude that
was so simple it was such a small thing
it was five days of getting out there a
few times like but everything's always
it's always relative whose ideas oh it
willit so whatever year it was over a
thousand college students who I was our
only it was our only audience we were
also writing songs at the same time so
like I got married in 2000 we started
getting the other venue and Jesse
weren't married until 2001 I would get
together at your apartment and we would
write songs we wrote enough songs by
getting together every week that we also
made a CD at that point cuz just malleus
the Grammy was 2001 right yeah right yes
yes we were writing all this song first
album was 2001 so we made a CD of comedy
songs some of which one of those songs
the unibrow song we got we performed on
stage at Christmas conference along with
Tim playing harmonica I think this is
the thing that is gonna be news to
everybody so we talked about those early
songs like the unibrow song the Facebook
song that which was a few years later
but yes all those early songs and the
unibrow song was the first thing that
was ever featured on the homepage of
YouTube again we told this story before
about how my home video of LOC crying
after Carolina Beach State was featured
and that well the YouTube wanted to
feature it and we were like listen
that's just a home video will you
feature the work that we actually care
about and that was the unibrow song that
was kind of the beginning of us getting
traction on YouTube but anyway we'll get
into that was many years later that was
2006 or 7 but anyway those are songs
that we wrote at the time we wrote them
for Christmas conference we wrote them
to perform live period
yeah the unibrow song was I mean in the
first batch of songs that we wrote but
actually we wrote a song because a
friend Greg who we talked about last
week was getting married in December of
2000 yeah and at his rehearsal dinner we
were like hold on we're wearing your
wedding party that means we're your
rehearsal dinner your rehearsal dinner
means that everybody's sitting down in
chairs eating and something
give a toast that's an audience Greg
we're gonna write a song and perform it
for your family and Jin's family at your
rehearsal dinner so we wrote a song and
the chorus was we've seen Greg naked
soon you will too hope you enjoy it more
than we do
right and Tim played the harmonica and
sing it with us and then although we
were his roommates and then on the way
home from the rehearsal dinner with
Christy and Jesse and again we've told
this story this part of it they said I
remember they were sitting in the car
waiting for us to get back to the car
and they had been talking yeah and we
got on a car and they said we just think
that y'all need to do something with
this with your comedy thing that you
just did in there because you know what
it really worked
those people were really into it and
there's something there and y'all need
to pursue this and you know it was a
pivotal moment the 80 80 people in the
room laughing at us making fun of the
the groom you know what they had the
vision to say you know there's something
here but the implication was to pursue
it beyond just doing Christmas
conference and I think we were already
doing that and I think that's why when
we started writing songs
we took that song that we wrote for Greg
we changed the lyrics and made it about
the unibrow and performed it at
Christmas conference a month later or
whatever right and then we started in
early 2001 we started writing more songs
that then we made a CD we're like well
we got all these songs we'll make a CD
you're just trying stuff you know and we
would sell it at Christmas conference
the next year yeah and so I mean again
we ended up in seeing the Christmas code
for a total of ten years so this is
gonna we're gonna kind of good but just
some of the stuff that we were doing
again this is like we were figuring out
what rhett and Link comedy was and it
was a combination of you know getting up
there in front of a group of people I
think this is one of the reasons that we
do things like this podcast and we do
good mythical morning and we do things
the way that we do is just like the two
of us talking to a group of people is
because the foundation of it was getting
up there at conference and doing
routines together
loosely scripted yeah things interacting
with people going out into the crowd
making these videos singing these songs
all the things that basically are all
the pieces of our career we did it I'll
give some example we one of the first
videos we made in none of the videos
were religious all the videos were just
purely comedic I think what we didn't I
don't know that we call ourselves
comedians but over time we started to
think of ourselves as comedians you know
you start to make a musical comedy CD
and you start to think of yourself in
this way on this totally different track
in this Christian world but we were very
self-conscious to never be Christian
comedians because just like way back in
the days of wax paper dogs we were very
self-conscious being a Christian band
it's like there was a stigma associated
okay a second-rate comedian no we just
want to make things that we think as
funny as possible and we can plug them
into this context in these conferences
where it's like you find it funny here
you can find it funny anywhere hopefully
yeah so everything we created was more
often than not was didn't there was no
religious undertone sir there was no
message it was just this is just to be
funny now when we were on stage and we
were introducing speakers and stuff like
that you might can you might
contextualize something like a video
where you're a dog like life as a dog
but it's just you crawling around on all
fours and then having POV shots of you
as a dog I don't even know why it was
funny probably was well it cuz who let
the dogs out I was popular at the time
okay yeah that that makes it all made
sense at this point that's all you need
is a song and an idea we people at
conference you had to share a bed with
like a roommate it'll be like four
people two people to a bed so we made
this sketch called the invisible bed
fence if you got to share a bed with
somebody that you don't want to be
removing romantically involved with you
just string up this invisible bed fence
kind of like what you would have for a
dog in a yard and it would shock you so
we created a fake commercial for this
product I was on YouTube for a while but
it had copyrighted music because that
was back in the day where no one thought
about that so now it's been taken down
we would also film some videos
while at conference we went over to the
mall across the street from the
conference in Greensboro and we took
nose hair trimmers and we trimmed
strangers nose hairs and then tried to
sell them this amazing new device
they've never seen if that sounds like
it's funny just that one is still on
YouTube because it's got royalty-free
music it's I don't think it's funny I
think it's embarrassing I think we
should pull it down but just for s-sarah
t it's still up there it's so bold that
we did it we also we would also do
things on stage like bits on stage where
we would invite students so we got to
guys - we had an idea called y'all
gained 12 pounds which i think is
probably it would be a little more
controversial 20 years later but at the
time it seemed funny to get two guys who
were in relatively good shape to try to
gain 12 pounds over the course of five
days and you know what they did in less
than five and I think four days one of
the guys gained 12 pounds and then we
changed the name of it - y'all gained 14
pounds right right right
and it was just a dude who was drinking
whole milk whole milk every day
hey can you believe that somebody could
gain 12 pound I mean is that something
that wrestlers do I know wrestlers lose
them really easily but that we but know
what if we get him to gain the way we
did another one called the progressive
haircut gradual haircuts we got two guys
out there and everyday everyday a
conference we would cut more of his hair
off giving him a different hairstyle of
it so he looked like an idiot the entire
conference right this is just good clean
fun man yeah we were loving it I mean
and again we were just volunteers where
I worked at a cubicle you worked at a
cubicle and then we get together we'd
get together once a week and we come up
with this stuff and whatever all year
long we'd be looking towards Christmas
conference where we could unleash these
ideas we don't say one thing before we
talk about before we take a break and
talk about the sort of the pivotal thing
that happen but I think it's important
to acknowledge like I said I think that
the old video is not funny right it we
needed a cocoon to develop in I'm gonna
be honest with you right we were we're
kind of late bloomers in a lot of ways
and I ain't like you know there are
really talented like teenagers who are
like really funny you think about
somebody like Bo Burnham yeah exactly
you know like that dude was doing
next-level genius level content and
comedy as a 15 year old we were not we
were not doing that as 25 year olds in
fact we were still in and I don't and
I'm not saying we're like comedic genius
geniuses at this point we've got a lot
of lucky breaks but we're a lot better
than we were but we needed sort of a
sheltered environment we could not have
succeeded in a place where comedy was
what was expected we succeeded in a
place where comedy was a surprise these
it was like it was like going to church
and having a funny pastor right we were
funny pastors let's just be I let's just
be honest and that's how we got away
with it because people were there for
the meat which was what are we gonna
learn about Jesus y'all that's why we're
all here and we were like well right
before you learn about Jesus these two
Nimrods are gonna get up there to use a
biblical reference memorize these two
Nimrods are gonna get up there and just
cut the fool and some people are gonna
find you in those hairs and you know
what some people are gonna be annoyed by
it a lot of people were I'm sure because
we thought we were so great yeah and we
weren't but we needed that environment
to develop and that's why we just owe a
lot to again Mike Mahaffey giving us the
opportunity to do this believing in us
letting us develop and then he thought
it was funny and then marked worked with
us at the Christmas conference right and
Mark worked directly with us for a
minute before the main meeting and Todd
as well was involved was involved so I
think that yeah we just we got so lucky
like we would not our idea of full time
entertainment growing up was the guy who
came to our dance and in deejay the
dance you know and just like wore boots
and had this like speaker that he can
came out with or like a magician we
didn't understand what full-time
entertainment was we didn't have any
appreciation for what comedy was besides
just what we had seen on television we
did and we didn't have a plan that this
was going to lead to something beyond it
but it was irresistible for us to stay
involved in what it was and that's why
nine years after you graduated from
college we were MC in this conference
still still now the pivotal moment
there's a pivotal moment again involving
my brother shortly after we graduated
and we had emceed conference a few times
that I think sort of represents the next
big evolution the next big step he could
see that we were trying really hard yeah
and we're gonna talk about that in just
a second but first actually we don't do
we have with links to them wearing the
same I'm wearing the same shirt you can
still buy it go to mythical com get all
times there's other TVs and you know
what and now we're selling Bibles I'm
still on the fence about how much I can
joke because we haven't fully unpacked
everything but there it is
there's a Bible joke mythical calm repet
bows let's get back into this ok so
again I don't know exactly what year it
was but it had to be between 2000 and
2002 yes let's say 2001 to say 2001 your
brother was the my brother was on staff
at UNC yep
they had that because they add their own
weekly meeting every one every every
campus has you know every campus has
several ministries but most major
colleges have a division of Cru a
chapter I don't know what the technical
term is so Cole says hey got an idea for
you guys to do a comedy show on campus
that's an outreach that's the term that
we use was outreach and the whole idea
behind outreach is it is an event where
the intention is you bring people who
are not Christians to the event so
you can reach out to them and share the
gospel with them so that hopefully they
will become Christians their lives will
be changed that's the premise and we
always being super self-aware one of the
things we were very self-aware about you
know and actually very critical about
when it came to the church is the idea
of what we call bait-and-switch
evangelism so this is the idea where you
tell somebody like hey there's gonna be
this cool debate like we're debating
creation creation and evolution or
there's a guy coming and he's an FBI
profiler and he's a real he's gonna give
a speech all about the fact that he's
because this is literally something to
happen and he's an FBI profiler and he's
gonna talk about his career in profiling
people and you get somebody who's not
interested in spiritual things to be
interested in that thing the bait you
bring them to the event they hear about
the thing but then pretty early on
sometimes it at the very end all of a
sudden there's a switch and it's like
huh they're talking about Jesus now and
they're telling me that the most
important thing in life is a
relationship with Jesus and that's why
all these people are here and this FBI
profiler is saying that listen I'm an
FBI profiler I'm really good at it I
just demonstrated that but the real
important thing in my life is Christ and
maybe he did a better job of
transitioning than you just did but
there was a paraphrase but it did it
would switch up and there will be an
opportunity for you unsuspecting guests
to make some sort of some sort of
indication a lot of times it was just
like indicate on a sheet of paper and
we'll send you some information or
whatever we didn't like that even when
we were a part of it we didn't like it I
was always like this just doesn't seem
sincere it's like if you if you want
people to understand that Jesus has made
a life a difference in your life tell
them that don't tell them hey let's talk
about this other thing and I'm gonna
suddenly I just never liked it you never
liked it so when Cole said let's do an
outreach we knew that we weren't gonna
do that kind of outreach but we knew we
were going to do something yeah cuz all
of a sudden this is an audience at
Carolina and we believed in the cause
and
we say no to an audience is is it just
felt so stupid to us never saying we got
it we got to find a way to do this what
we ended up doing I don't there's
anybody video that I hope not
well the premise was it was just a
comedy show but we would bring up topics
it was a salty the term that we would
use in Christian circles is it was salty
so Christians see themselves as the salt
of the earth and so you're the salt and
you're the light and so sometimes you
just want to be salt you don't want to
come all the way out and explicitly say
something you just want to keep it kind
of salty and you're sort of suggesting
the message of Jesus our idea was we
wanted we wanted to dissin we wanted to
dismantle some of the preconceived
notions about Christianity maybe hit
some of those things head-on give the
audience member give the the students
who were involved in crew who brought a
friend something that then they could
talk about afterwards so like there were
multiple topics that we hit that like
hey if you're gonna go and grab a taco
afterward you can say when he said when
they were talking about this like that
Christians were just well we had it now
we would characterize look look we had
until the tuxedo story yeah so but that
was the premise that was a bad that was
our version of like a the least version
of bait-and-switch we could do something
that's just it was a conversation for
conversation conversation starter and
then take it where you want to take it
afterward so well we had been really
influenced by some people who talked
about relational evangelism
it's what the term that was being used
at the time yeah and so it was like you
have a relationship with somebody and
sometimes you need sort of prompts in
that relationship in the context of that
friendship to talk about things and
maybe that will then get to a place
where you can talk about Jesus it still
sounds very manipulative in sales money
and it can be and is often but I we
thought our version was less
manipulative than the bait and switch
evangelism no more the show when you
think when you're convinced that your
friends are going to hell you got it
it's you got to come up with something
right yeah yeah oh yeah exactly yeah I
mean I remember Penn Jillette
said this at one point years ago when I
still believe the way that I used to
believe and he just said that like any
Christian who actually believes that
people are going to hell if they don't
know Jesus hasn't completely devoted
almost every aspect of their life to
telling people about Jesus something's
missing and that that seemed very
logical and motivating to me but but
from a personal standpoint still
embarrassed he kind of nodded ass up
because this is so self-aware and it was
this like something it just doesn't it
still didn't sit right but again we had
to find a way forward and we did that
and we we felt like we needed to wear
tuxedos I don't know why but we had
tuxedos we we ordered tuxedos and of
course I had to have mine tailored to
fit me and but we picked it up on the
night of the show like we picked it up
and I tried it on literally like 30
minutes before and backstage I'm putting
my tuxedo on you're wigging out now let
me just explain you know at the time I
was about the same size 34 waist 34 to
36 the length of pants the waist was
great I believe these were 34 waist
tuxedo pants but they were approximately
28 length no maybe 26 you talking like
they hit me way up the shin half-caff
half decaf pants man that really takes
the confidence out of a comedian in his
comedy show first-ever comedy show wait
mean this was over an hour this is like
an hour in ten minutes of us singing
songs having monologue dialogues with
each other playing some games of the
audience I don't think it mattered that
I think it probably only helped people
well we were still kind of on the tail
end of the era of Steve Martin and
Martin Short and I think that they okay
they often they often wore those
half-caf tuxedos anyway so again like
link said the whole point of this thing
was to dismantle people's perceptions
about Christians we started the whole
night with a an acronym Christians are
blank blank and when you went through
each letter I remember Aurra was like
Republic
like we're making fun of people's
perception that like people think that
all a conservative Republican we knew
that that was like a big turn-off and a
lot of people were like white why are
your politics so tied to your faith and
so we were like trying to dismantle that
I think in the end it it was not a
resounding success in in much of any way
except the fact that we did something
that wasn't a conference we created
something we created a show creator in a
show and even if it was even if it
sucked we did it and people that people
were simple the audience was sympathetic
the I was left they laughed and it
wasn't a failure it wasn't a failure and
it didn't crush us in another pivotal
moment in our careers we were wrapping
up cleaning up walking out and I
remember sitting on the front steps of
this auditorium at UNC I can't remember
the name of that Hill hall I think it
may have been yeah sitting on the steps
there
Shane Daiki who was also on staff with
Campus Crusade sits us down he's kind of
a bigwig he had you know he'd traveled
the globe he was he was a he was a
higher up leader yeah and he'd also
emceed some stuff that we had seen he
was very funny guy you're funny super
nice super black great MC sort of like
you know and that the comedic style that
we were going for yeah and he said you
know guys I think that what you did
tonight could be a ministry I think you
guys could be on staff with Campus
Crusade doing what you did tonight and
we thought about that and you know when
you just have when you're going back to
your cubicle and then you're just
thinking about okay a few months we got
this now we'll be done maybe we could do
that again and then we've got Christmas
conference that we do every year and I
would love to do more yeah I would love
to do more well again
so we get labeled because we blazed a
trail on YouTube sometimes sometimes we
get called innovative or
again listen like this just how the
stuff just happened to us like we
haven't blazed many trails what we've
done is just we've been receptive and
open at different points an
opportunistic opportunistic and listen
when Shane Daiki said you guys could
just you could do this full-time it
wasn't like it was strategic for us we
were thinking about that we were like
really that sounds awesome how do we do
that he said well what you need to do is
you need to put together a proposal for
the regional team so this is the team of
people in the mid-south region who make
decisions about who is going to be on
staff and it because basically the way
Campus Crusade for Christ staff works
and other ministries college ministries
like it is you have to you get on staff
by like going through like an
application or approval process by the
people who make these decisions and then
you just get assigned to a campus
usually right but there are other
different roles that you could that you
can play within the organization but
everybody gets paid the same way and
that is through something called raising
support meaning it isn't like crusade
has this big bank somewhere and they
just pay people salaries when you get
hired you then have to go out and ask
individual people for monthly donations
to build up your salary 100% of it 100%
not is not a back filled by like a a
large fund right so this opportunity it
was daunting because that's what it
meant you you need you have to you can't
you can't do it halfway you have to be
you have to you have to quit your job as
engineers and you have to raise
financial support once you've reached
your goal region support then you can go
out you can move to your assignment and
my brother had already gone out and
asked all the people that I was gonna
ask yank about that yeah and for me we
had well-paying jobs as engineers yoga
and I had my first child on the way
my wife Christy she taught school for
one year then she got pregnant and she
was she was basically she was joining
she was on staff along with me as a
full-time mom so she didn't it's not
like she had a job you came on staff as
a family and raised all your financial
support you couldn't have any other jobs
because you you needed to be fully
devoted to it or whatever so this was
this is a huge decision and we were very
motivated to find a way to make it work
I also knew that like it was going to be
a shock to my extended family if I were
to announce hey you know they were so
proud of me being a working engineer
right and proud of the volunteer work
that I was doing on the side but it it
it took a while for them to come around
to the decision that Christy and I made
and it you and Jesse made and the four
of us make you know it was like the four
of us are making a decision because
rhettandlink really want to do this
thing because you guys gave us a speech
in a car after Gregg's rehearsal dinner
you know it's like it was dicey man
because it was freaking scary to just
say oh yeah I'm just gonna quit my job
and then I'm gonna start from scratch
and I'm just gonna get people to give me
money every month through the
organization tax-deductible now the
thing is I you know true my brother was
already on staff and he was already
getting supported by people but did that
kind of cut book to ways not only did it
mean that a lot of people that I was
going to ask had already been asked by
him but I also understood that it could
be done I had seen somebody do it who
and my parents have seen somebody do it
I don't know exactly what they thought
about it at the time I think they were
probably kind of excited that we were
saying hey we wanted to go into
full-time ministry but they were
probably like oh we're gonna have
another son who's going around asking
people for money
yeah I'm me and Christy's side of the
equation it was foreign to almost
everybody that we talked to especially
both of our families in in talking about
the decision and we had a baby on the
way I think I already said that but
as couples we believed in the choice and
as a group we supported each other in in
making the leap like I resigned from my
job at IBM you resigned I think as they
were trying to lay you off yes I want to
tell that story because that's a that's
a new piece of the story but let me back
up just one second because I want to
talk about what our proposal was because
we had to go ahead before we could do
all this quit we didn't want to be
assigned to a campus well so
specifically we developed a proposal
which ironically and coincidentally one
of our good friends Matt Harmon hat week
we had sent it to him 20 years ago for
like his opinion and he had it and he
was like I just found this and he sent
it back to us last week yeah I rented it
so when we read the proposal so again we
were super into this idea of moving away
from this bait and switch evangelism
idea that we had seen done on so many
campuses and we wanted to equip students
first of all we didn't want to go around
doing outreaches and so if you're not
gonna do outreaches what's the
alternative well you can train so we
actually create we the idea was that we
were gonna create events that the Campus
Crusade students would come to all these
campuses in the mid-south and the whole
point was we're gonna do this comedy
show but really what we're doing is
we're trying to equip you in thinking
about the way that you talk to people
about Jesus we want you to get to a
place where you have friends and you're
willing to talk to them about Jesus and
you learn ways to do that and you're not
just thinking constantly about inviting
them to events and stuff but you make it
a part of your lifestyle that was the
idea
we made the pitch and they said yes do
it and we said we also want to continue
to host the the events that we've been
hosting and more if there's
opportunities you know they said sure so
they were very supportive they believed
in the vision and they also said what
you got a raise your own support so get
to it it's pretty easy it's pretty easy
to say okay when you know
proof is really a hen you raise them up
right yourself but they were supportive
and they gave us the go-ahead and then
that once they give us a go-ahead
that's where it that was the biggest
single decision from a career personal
family standpoint that I made in this
whole thing I mean there was another
there's a second there's a second place
that we'll talk about when we left staff
but joining staff quitting engineering
that was a huge moment for the next year
well I gotta tell Mike I gotta tell Mike
okay okay story tell you quitting story
so again the story that you've heard is
that we quit our jobs and became
youtubers you're now learning that
that's not exactly what happened
what happened with me was is it was - I
guess it was 2002 so I basically it was
my second year of working in engineering
like I'd worked a total of two years and
it was the end of that year now towards
the second half of that year probably
like September October of 2002 we had
made the decision that we were going to
do this and we had gotten approval to be
on staff and so I was like okay I'm
going to work at Black & Veatch the
engineering firm that I was working at
through the end of the year and then
I'll tell them like you know like 30
days or whatever before the end of the
year that hey I'm I'm quitting and I'm
gonna go do a different job well
literally like two weeks before I told
them that I was gonna quit this was back
when the Enron thing was happening and
they were late all these could we design
power plants and so a lot of the firms
were just having like rounds and rounds
of layoffs so like for weeks people were
getting laid off and laid off and laid
off and then one week all the engineers
that got hired on the same day as me all
the junior engineers they started
getting called into the office and they
would come back and be escorted out and
so I was like oh no I'm gonna I'm next
no something like McLoughlin please come
down to the so-and-so room
and everybody at that point knew that we
were getting laid off I go down there I
had a conversation with vollis he felt
real bad I said hey listen man don't
worry I was actually gonna quit and
instead of like out it was when a girl
dumps you and you say yeah I was gonna
dump you anyway but then I remember
going back upstairs to get my belongings
than being escorted out now by a cop but
by like another employee and then
everybody's like all the other engineers
were like trying to be sad and you know
empathetic and this one girl I can't
remember her name but she was like I'm
so sorry and I said you know what don't
worry about me I'm gonna go be a
missionary I'm sure that made her feel
oh that's great as soon as I said that I
was like why did I phrase it like that
but I'm gonna just keep walking yeah I
knew he was Mormon biggest decision we
ever made
scariest decision we ever made for the
next year your full-time job was meeting
with individuals usually at their home
and giving them a presentation which
ended with will you make a pledge for
annual or monthly support so I can do
this thing that I've told you about for
an hour yeah I did the same thing for a
year at the end of that year you went to
the office and started working because
you had reached your financial support
but we got you forgot we also we also
worked at the same time because you got
to have money so doing something I did
not get done by the end of that year it
took me an additional year and over the
course of that time we were both trying
to work part-time jobs in order to make
ends meet while we're meeting with
people and so for me that was two years
of meeting with people there was a there
were there was a whole section of months
where we lived with Christy's family in
her the room she grew up in it's like it
was it was it was extremely difficult I
lived for a year above my in-laws garage
and you did some odd jobs for him that's
where I impregnated my wife with my
first child
okay great in a bubble garage yeah Lily
was born yeah so and I and I my
father-in-law had like a bunch of he's a
dentist but he had had a bunch of
properties and stuff and
I was kind of like his gofer and just
did a painted stuff and organized stuff
and drove his truck around and it was
just like odd jobs blue-collar odd jobs
for a full year
it was weird I went there was a period
where I had to ask my dad it was very
humbling I asked my dad if he could hire
me and my dad paid me to just work for
him laying tile and like he pretty he
was like I can pay you an apprentice
rate because you don't know what you're
doing and you know it was how about pay
me the son rate he what you know it's
like he did everything he could and it
made all the difference in the world but
it was it was it was tough and then Lily
was born and we were still raising
support and we would take this newborn
in and try to time our appointments
where she would sleep through the whole
thing or a Christi would have to leave
and I remember one it would always be
the same spiel but I remember in one one
spiel I looked up as I'm trying to be
engaging and trying to like get people
motivated to give money and this guy who
was a friend of a friend of a friend of
Christy's dad and I knew he had a lot of
money
I looked up from like my presentation
notes or whatever and the dude was
asleep he had fallen asleep and it was
just the three of us in a room talking
about the ministry work we wanted to do
he still he I woke him up with some
grunts and he did make a pledge so
mission accomplished yeah so two years
of that then we finally start working on
we could talk about the project we're
dealing process of raising support
forever I've got a bunch of crazy
stories but essentially it's got too
much other state was awkward as you can
imagine going around at people's homes
and asking them for money but yes so
eventually we get to the point where
we've raised support we we came on staff
while jesse was pregnant we started
working in the regional office which was
a little office and like with cubicles
and apex North Carolina and Jesse was
pregnant at the time and we worked she
worked for like two months before like
January and February then Locke was born
on january of february 24th of 2004 so
jesse was actually in the office for a
little bit but then i was just left
there by myself waiting for what you
need to get there to finish and i spent
most of my time like kind of plant we
knew what we were gonna do like we knew
we were gonna do some kind of show so i
just kind of was thinking about
christmas conference of course cuz
always thinking about christmas
conference but kind of putting together
the groundwork for the show that we
would take around campuses yeah and i
eventually got there and so we were
sitting in a in a little cubicle
environment and there was a one back
room where the door was shut and you
could edit videos and that kind of
became our default office and we would
make our plans for the the tour we would
do around the mid-south region with our
training seminar and for conference and
then at some point in in doing the tour
in doing in yeah and doing the tour and
then coming back and want to promote it
we were like we need to have a website
so we created a website and we started
putting our comedy videos up on our
website rhettandlink.com/store
in order to promote our visits to campus
like hey these guys are coming you
should come out check out these videos
and they were videos that we had debuted
at Christmas conference and stuff like
that but now of a sudden we had a
portfolio on our website and we were
still making we made pimp my stroller
after Locke was born and we debuted pimp
my stroller at Christmas conference to
the end of that year we showed the video
and then we were at when the video is
over we rolled the stroller out on stage
with Lily and lock in the stroller and
the crowd went crazy and that same year
like another day we pulled up Facebook
profiles of students in the audience and
made fun of their Facebook profiles and
then at the end of that comedy bit we
sing a new song that we had written
called the Facebook song right and that
was the end of it and then we did our
tour we had our put our videos on our
website and then Apple released
this part of this thing called iTunes
and they had this section called video
podcast I'm like we already have videos
beside hold on this is different these
videos are made for this platform and
they're like they're serial one of the
biggest things was a a ninja who would
answer questions I was asked a ninja and
so we said well what's our version of
that we can do because we wanted to do
stuff like that was you know we can our
rationale was on one hand we can create
content for the Internet first and then
the people who will see it will be the
people who will want us to come to their
campus so it's all a promotional tool
for our for our live tool and it was
also the idea was we did like the idea
of people inviting other people both
Christians and non-christians to our
event because it was friendly to whoever
you were it was it was about training
right in conversations but we weren't
trying to hide anything but it but so it
was like if we can make these videos and
like college students actually watch
them and care about them then maybe
they'll be excited about coming to the
events so we were making videos for the
events we were writing songs well were
they let's talk I want to talk a little
bit about what the event was because
it's kind of a really interesting time
in our lives like yeah you know it would
basically be me and you know there was a
one time when we took Jesse and
Christine the kids in a big van and it
was not great yeah we just wanted my
Teleco talked about that he was mostly
me and you driving and we had all we had
a projector and a laptop and your guitar
and a guitar and we would show up at
whatever like facility we had been
designated to do our show in which is
usually a classroom like a big college
classroom you know light wood that could
hold like 100 or 200 students and like
we would meet somebody with crew who was
like oh I'm the tech guy who can like
get your we had a projector and then we
had this like stand we would set all
this stuff up like the projector and the
Mustaine and then we had a we had a it
was all in PowerPoint or keynote maybe
the jack you know
and we had a little remote and like we
just did the whole presentation with
their we didn't take anybody with us to
do this no and it was like and then we
would like do it and then we would like
go eat somewhere I go watch a movie like
it was just me and you traveling the
country together with this show it was
awesome it was an interesting time that
yeah it was the training part we
believed in it but personally we weren't
that great at it it's not like when I
when I worked as an engineer I was like
engaging all these people talking about
my faith it was like you know they were
great about talking about doing we were
training other people but it was so
there was this dichotomy of like on one
hand we believe in what we're doing and
what we're saying but we're also very
motivated to continue to create and
engage an audience and I think it was
and that really fueled everything we did
to make it I mean we weren't gonna do it
half-ass and we weren't gonna we weren't
we were gonna honor the people who were
investing every single month in in the
vision that we laid out to them right
well but we were also developing and
maybe more so than we realized as as
entertainers and I think especially when
we started doing the videos started
doing more videos now the timeline is a
little bit interesting because a lot of
the videos that you can go you know we
didn't join YouTube in 2006 and we'll
talk about how that happened but a lot
of the videos when we first joined we
just took this backlog of videos all the
way from 2003 or earlier we just
uploaded them to YouTube and some of
those videos are still up there
so one of our earliest videos is when we
talked about velcro and we've made fun
of ourselves before because we're
sitting like we was we did this like
podcast where well and here's why we we
this is what I was getting out earlier
we didn't care about YouTube but Apple
seemed legitimate and when they were
doing video podcast I sure liked it lots
of farting noises let me just if I can
work them out okay
apples seem legitimate and when they
they started platforming these video
podcasts and asking ninja was the
biggest one we said let's develop
something for that platformer I just
can't put the videos that we've made
over the past few years on and Apple is
not gonna do anything with that
we got to have a video podcast that's
why it was called the red link cast and
so we developed that and the rationale
was that would be promotion for when we
visit campuses for whatever we're doing
increased increase our awareness within
the movement of Campus Crusade but it
was also exciting to develop a show that
was for the internet first and that's
the first time that we actually did that
and the first thing we did we started
doing debates like if if the ninja can
answer questions then we can play
characters who debate topics and we did
that maybe once twice maybe maybe twice
I think we did it well but the thing I
don't wanna get into some of these
details are not gonna be interesting to
people but I the one thing I want to dis
acknowledge is that you know the first
year that we worked doing this we worked
at the regional office and we had a
little room that we would go in and this
is where we would shoot our videos and
we would shoot the and we shot the
rhettandlink cast a Velcro one was the
first one that we did when we started
when we decided on that on the format of
the two of us sitting behind a table
with microphone one microphone in front
of us talking right so that was the
beginning of that format which as you
know led to eventually a good mythical
morning many years later but the
interesting thing is we've made fun of
ourselves and the way we talked in that
video and how we were talking well
especially link was talking really seven
and really hacking light the reason that
he was talking so we were both talking
so quietly is because we were in an
office with people working right outside
this room we've never talked about that
but it's like there's people like doing
their Campus Crusade regional office job
in the cubicles and then we're in there
talking about velcro we're sketching
velcro pictures and talking about them
and part of it was what are you guys
doing I mean we're out here doing like
legitimate work you're in here talking
about velcro for an Internet video on
this thing that nobody
understands so it's like Mao it probably
better if you didn't hear us so in 2000
I'm gonna guess that it was 2005 we knew
that we needed our own space and it was
just because the ideas that we had in
the way that we wanted to do them even
just for what we were doing in the
ministry was too big for this place that
we're at who disruptive destructible
environment and I talked to my
father-in-law and then the office that
we that I broke into during one of the
elta episodes last year where it talks
about how we went in there and we saw
all the stuff that place that basement
in Lillington North Carolina where we
first did so many of our videos that was
the place he was like sure I've got a
basement I've got a basement and
Lillington I'm just storing stuff in
there if you guys want to work out of
there no problem and so that was the
beginning we went in there that was when
we painted the wall green and blue we
did the chequered the you know the black
and white check floor that are all these
iconic things that now have made their
way to the set of gmm like that was all
because of that Lillington basement when
we need we knew we needed a space and so
that we could create the video podcast
to promote our tour as missionaries yeah
and shout out to David Woodall yeah who
was working with us at the time he was
at the regional office and he started
working closely with us kind of just
like running camera and he helped us lay
that tile in there and the carpet and
paint and all this stuff like basically
getting our office into the state that
it was for the number of years that we
knew that we worked in I loved it I mean
we had our own little basement hideout
no one was looking over our shoulder in
questioning how does this directly
relate to the ministry it's like we were
just going on instinct and we were
working really hard but it really wasn't
clear if it was if it was 100% aligned
or if it was worth it or if it was just
stupid well for instance it was in that
basement that we conceptualize the idea
to make looking for miss Locklear the
documentary where we tried to find our
first grade teacher and again we got
approval for all this stuff the vision
was we were going to take that
documentary
and then we were going to use it we had
already done two tours and so then
instead of doing a third tour we were
gonna shoot the documentary in 2000 that
was two that summer 2006 and then we
were going to take that documentary and
use it and screen it and use it for
training purposes again you watch a
documentary you you won't see any of
that there's no there's no overtly we're
using it as an upper way to say you
could take anything that has any sort of
meaning to it and use it to get into a
conversation about Jesus and it was the
idea but we never got to do that because
some things and I will I will say this
story may serve is like a classic
example of what you can't give people a
lot of a lot of leeway you know it's
like there's probably like you know I
give credit to Don Knox I remember him
saying I don't know he was our he was
our supervisor yeah gave us a lot of
freedom he was like I don't know exactly
what you guys are doing but I believe in
you guys and I trust you guys yeah and I
think he did have good reason to trust
us I do I do think and we were you had
great intentions but some things ended
up happening I think that being
independent being down there making that
documentary taking it to film festivals
having people respond to it wants some
awards it got screened on PBS as part of
the whatever that's SCTV doc your line
documentary light lens thing we began to
get this idea that we began to gain
confidence I think it was at that point
in sort of those like Oh 506 again June
of oh six is when we shot looking for
miss Locklear but it's also when we
started our YouTube channel and the only
reason we started a YouTube channel
to tell a story we've told a million
times is because somebody took that pimp
my stroller video that we made for
Christmas conference and put on our
website they put it on YouTube got more
video today than it had in a year on our
so then we put everything on YouTube but
again you're like well there's an
audience there but it really was hey all
we got to do is press upload it was not
strategic it was like hey let's put
things on the art we didn't know we
weren't making a plan to get off staff
at that point now
saying but these videos started develop
a life of their own I mean even the ones
within the that we were making
specifically just for the podcast like
we would sing a song about Velcro or a
fear of frogs and we would be talking
and then we got an email one day from
Phil Vischer create a creator of
VeggieTales
now you know Bob the Tomato Larry the
Cucumber well he specifically the voice
of it many of the characters but Bobby
tomato yeah he created created the whole
world well I'm not gonna tell his story
but once what he told it in a book what
you know what after after he was pretty
much done working with VeggieTales
and he was starting a new thing called
jelly telly and it was a website for a
new type of kids programming that was
Christian education for kids like a
Christian Sesame Street with puppets in
some live action and he said he wanted
he wanted to give us he thought we could
work together and we developed some
characters he said he wanted us to sing
songs about the books of the Bible he
said that between him as one of his
characters and then us they wanted to
essentially sing a song about every book
of the Bible and they were gonna start
from the beginning and he wanted to give
us Genesis and then they I think take
every other book and this was gonna go
into this what's in the Bible DVD series
that will be sold in Christian
bookstores and also a website called
jelly telly and this is why you may and
many of you have found them because they
are on YouTube you may find these guys
the fabulous Bentley brothers which is
obviously me and Link in wigs sitting on
a stage looking like we're out of the
50s singing these songs about this funny
songs about the Bible it was a part of
that and doing that again we got
approval to do that because it's like oh
yeah why why shouldn't we let
rhettandlink do this this is a great
opportunity is still within the the is
still a ministry but we wrote the songs
we produced them under his supervision
we flew up to somewhere around Wheaton
Illinois and then we recorded in his
studio met him it was it was kind of a
thrill he was he was super nice he had
some mentorship influence on us we came
back we started to think what if we
worked with Phil on this thing and we
wrote up on a proposal
hey the proposal worked before we wrote
up a long proposal a business plan for
how we could be full-time employees and
maybe partners I don't know working with
Phil Vischer on his new endeavor well
and to give some context of that there's
like what they were just trying to make
well again what started as this is again
I think that we always were most
passionate just to be completely honest
we were most passionate about the
performance and the product and the and
the audience and then growing it we
really believed in the in the mission
and Campus Crusade and I think it yeah
but we but it was video podcast it was
really easy to take anything that we
were doing and tie it back to the
mission but what we were really
experiencing was like we were growing as
artists and we were experiencing the
satisfaction that is creating and
creating for an audience and when it
seemed like that could become something
that we could just get paid to do it
started to make sense to be like why
don't we just do this because our job if
we can do exactly what we want to do
that's that's and that's the whole thing
about we could have never I don't think
that we could have ever succeeded in the
traditional comedy space I just don't
there's no way we needed never even
thought about oh we need it we were too
smart to know that we could we could try
to go up on an open mic night at Charlie
good nights in Raleigh
world in a comedy club and try to get up
there and and win that crowd over
we just didn't believe that we had it
but we well we didn't we we we never
talked about that right but we were
trying to make something work Phil
Vischer the response to our proposal was
I have no opportunity to like the one
you're describing it can't work but we
can still work on like a piece
type thing and you guys can still be on
staff and but around the same time we
started getting emails from people
wanting to use the videos that we were
putting online in different shows like
maybe the show and you know there's that
show in England on channel whatever it
was that people used to
yeah like about did yeah people wanted
our video started working and breaking
out
we gave permission for our fear frog
song to be used in a new clip show that
was going to be on the CW you know that
is the show that event that was became
online nation that after a series of
other events we actually auditioned and
got the job to host that television show
and we went missing anything before we
get to that I don't think so I mean cuz
that's the I'm sure we're missing some
stuff but I mean the the basic idea is
that I was gonna say the unicorn wrap is
one of those things that we made at
Christmas conference if you'll see that
it makes a lot more sense if you know
that this is just a video to introduce
two MCS to come on stage if you want to
see emcees then come see these emcees
but it was like right right well maybe
MC is just what you call a rapper so
then we call it the unicorn rap and it
got a lot of views on YouTube right but
it's like the the fear of frog song got
the attention of the online nation
producers at the same time i I just get
a kick out of it so I'm gonna go through
it really quickly
we made because we had to make a video
every week for our podcast which the
fear of frog song came from
there was also an explosion at a
chemical plant near my house and that
people were protesting it we made we had
to make a video that week so we made a
video called Apex chemical explosion
where we made fools of ourselves at a
protest it was funny
Oprah was somehow involved indirectly we
took that video we entered it in a radio
contest in Raleigh where the winner
which was us got to first class plane
tickets to see the Grammys and they
wanted us to make a videos of first
class I think it was just class
yes it was coach man but you call the
seats lay back I hadn't been on a lot of
point I remember we won the contest with
our apex chemical explosion they sent us
to the Grammys and said make a video
we'll put it on our radio station
website because you know that'll get a
lot of views they didn't give us
credentials to get on the red carpet but
that's what we wanted to do we made
sneaking on the Grammy red carpet video
which you can still watch on YouTube
when we went when they flew us to LA to
make that video the next morning we we
dropped off the paperwork with the
online nation producers and met them in
person and told them what we did at the
Grammys when we got back to North
Carolina we sent them that video I think
that I was told by them that that's the
video that made them think that we could
be hosts of the show so they contacted
us and we got the audition and then we
got the job well they said can you just
audition in a video like here's some
clips that would be on the show and can
you just say some things to introduce
the clips we sent that tape in and the
next thing you know they said we've
selected you to host the pilot we got
permission from Campus Crusade to fly
out and and film the pilot and if it got
picked up we would make a decision at
that point and then they decided to pick
the show up and I remember finding out
that the show at a network show 2007
we're still on staff well I came
maybe it's 2006 we're still on staff we
can't be screw sayed and we we had kind
of the pump had been primed for us to be
looking for opportunities to do
entertainment full-time that was we were
on that page we'd already made the
proposal to Phil Vischer
and then we had both already decided if
this show gets picked up this doesn't
mean we're moving to California but what
it does mean is that hey wait we made it
we're in the entertainment business man
yeah and that we got the word that the
show had been picked up in fact they
told us we didn't have to move they
would fly us out every other weekend
every other week to shoot or one week
out of the month to shoot a big
group at a time and you know the story
there we shot a decision we got erred
but the decision to leave stuff in order
to do that was that's the that's the
answer
it's kind of the answer to the question
that people always ask is how did you
decide to quit your jobs in order to
become entertainers well we got another
one that's when we quit our job we quit
being on staff not we didn't quit being
engineers in order to become hosts this
was literally three years almost four
years after we had quit and we had to
stop being well I got fired and quit on
the same day let's say that but four
years after being engineers that's when
we finally had a job in the
entertainment industry and it wasn't to
be youtubers it was to be television
hosts but it and also be youtubers
because that in our minds that
legitimize us and it gave us that we
would still be making YouTube videos but
that was the plan well because we took
the video remember like ghost ride the
farm was we would make videos for online
nation and then we post them on our
course we put them on the YouTube
channel because it was a show about
YouTube but what I'm saying is I
remember thinking the in again I feel
like the producers of that show were
also part of this I mean I remember one
of them saying yes pretty soon you're
gonna be pushing that stroller down the
street and Malibu like selling the
Hollywood dreams Dave Hurwitz yeah yeah
who was also before that he was the
producer of Fear Factor yeah I'm sure
Joe Rogan knew him well and so I was
like yeah I'm gonna be I'm gonna be in
Malibu little did I know that like
nobody lives in Malibu and except like I
know like Sandra Bullock or something
it's like but we I was bought into the
idea that this is it man we made it
we've transitioned we're gonna be
entertainers and this is way bigger than
YouTube because you time again it was
2006 we weren't making any money on you
there what you couldn't make money on
you we were making it we're making tens
of dollars on our website called a
revver that was the only place that was
doing any sort of rev share hence the
name revver but it was a much easier
decision because we were looking for
ways to
to do squarely what we were passionate
about and not have to work it around
being in a Christian ministry it's not
that we didn't believe in the Christian
ministry anymore at this point it was
just that it
we were so passionate about what we
wanted to do it wasn't an alignment and
it started we started to see the hints
and indications of it being disingenuous
on that on that front from an optical
stamp I'll get into this next week when
I kind of tell my story but I will say
at that in that year 2006-2007 my
perspective on my faith had big had
begun to change but it but it was not I
still was aligned with the mission I was
still an evangelical Christian that way
that was not in question but my
perspective on it had changed and sort
of the stage had been set for what would
kind of unfold over the next 15 years
okay but I'll get into that and but for
now I would just like to say that it was
an easier decision for us to make even
though it was the set it was that it was
the second biggest decision that we made
to to leave staff and to inform all of
our supporters that hey we were do we're
doing this now you no longer need to
support us and of course with the
support of our wives we made that
decision and I you know from a to
conclude this conversation just to kind
of look back I just have a couple of
observations well just to finish the
story really quick where you go back to
connect it to what we've said before the
show got cancelled after four episodes
we did get paid to do those four
episodes and we made more money probably
in those four episodes than we had made
in a year working for Campus Crusade I
don't remember the exact numbers but it
was pretty close to the same so we had a
buffer because we were living off a very
little amount of money but as soon as
that money as soon as they told us a
show was cancelled we had nothing we had
no job and we had no prospects but we
made a video about it
you can still watch I made the video
about it getting canceled this was
before YouTube Partner Program you
couldn't make any money off youtube
videos and that was this is where the
story picks up and we've told before
that's when we started doing the thing
when we made cold calls to businesses to
get them to sponsor our videos and that
was the beginning of our quote-unquote
YouTube career but let me say it's a
very lean times yeah for a couple of
years on and off for several years but
those first couple of years very lean in
terms of not making a lot of money off
these videos and then splitting it
between our two families but like I said
we were very very accustomed to living
off of very little money and so it
wasn't that big of a sacrifice but there
was a couple of times there where I was
convinced that we were gonna have to
stop and go back and ask some of those
same people for money yeah you know and
thankfully eventually some things fell
into place and we we moved past that
stage I think there's when I look back
on it there's two ways that I like to
think about it and one is like how did
this entire journey these like Lost
years impact like our our style our our
brand of comedy and then on the and then
the other thing is just from a logistic
and historic standpoint it's just even
having the opportunity where every
everything was so pivotal you know I'm
always so fascinating and how everybody
the vast majority of people who are so
I'll start with that the vast majority
of people who are who were making it on
making careers out of YouTube were just
out of kids who were just doing YouTube
for fun and then as they got popular
they started to realize that there was
money there and then they got people
they figured out a way to like make it a
career and people came on to help them
from a business standpoint but for us we
were grown-ass adults with children
when YouTube started our first video
like pin my stroller had both of our
kids in it it was about a stroller for
God's sake
I mean if it wasn't for everything that
we've gone we've stepped you through
over the last episode in this one we
would just be some some old guys who had
no clue we were just engineers you know
it's like we had to bide our time for
YouTube to exist so that then our videos
that we just had could go on it the fine
brothers are a good example of someone
who our age kind of I think you know
they when we interviewed them in this
podcast it's reminiscent of their story
that they were doing a bunch of videos
that were just living in weird places
that then they just plopped on YouTube
they were somehow biding their time and
creating for something that they knew
not yet what it was and in Campus
Crusade and the and being on staff and
everything we did there and everything
that we step through gave us the time so
that we could be a part of this movement
even though we were like a generation
too old for it and then because we were
a generation too old for it in the same
way that when we talked to Harley of
Epic Meal Time he was a teacher you know
he had a level of maturity and drive and
a different older perspective I guess so
most of those people would that to make
it happen a good business other make a
business out of it because we went when
we like incorporated well as an LLC I
think for the first in 2007 it was that
year 2007 we started what do we call it
we call it rhett rhett and Link
creations well creations LLC it almost
feels like we knew there was something
we didn't know what it was it was very
reminiscent of when we wrote when we our
blood oath we were we promise to do
something that we couldn't articulate
what it was we were just we had to find
a way to get any audience we were going
to try to engage with and we were going
to try to to meet them
not knowing what will come of it and I
would say that there was a there was at
least a slight sense of desperation and
a lot of the things that we were doing
which I think really led to a lot of the
things that we did especially becoming a
business you know it was it had to work
and therefore we we made it work but you
know to answer your question about the
tone of our comedy which is something
that people have speculated about for
years and it's one of the reasons that
we you know if you look at a lot of our
early videos it's like are they Mormon
or Christian or what are they you now
kind of understand why so much of our
comedy especially in the early days was
so it was clean as a whistle
yeah except for the you know like those
videos that we made in college where we
were naked we would push the envelope
and within that circle of you know the
Christian circle but the reality is is
that all these videos were made to be
shown and experienced within the context
of Christian events those first few
years of videos and therefore they can
only there's a whole lot of lines that
we couldn't cross there's a whole lot of
places that comedy goes that we couldn't
go now I do what I was also who we were
by and large I mean we did curse I mean
it's not like we didn't curse but we
were never gonna put that in a video
well I was gonna I was gonna say not
exactly that because I was gonna say
that like our personal comedy the way
that we would interact with each other
the jokes that we would tell to each
other when a camera wasn't rolling I've
always been pretty off-color
there's been cursing it wasn't like
something now you hear and see some of
that stuff in our comedy now I see it
less as we've changed we have we have
changed everybody changes but yeah I
think a lot of it is just we kind of let
our guard down because it's like the
environment that we're creating in is
not that what what it was but because we
initially attracted an audience that was
like oh this is clean comedy and clean
comedy aficionados gathered around and
then that was where we got pushed back
every time we pushed another limit you
know and we crossed another line slowly
usually on Facebook everybody would
complain and some people be like that's
the last video I'm ever watching that's
the last video I'm ever letting
kids watch but it helps you understand
the context of why we started that way I
think it's mostly because what who would
be the audience we were creating for in
the context of what these videos would
be showing us true then there's also
another aspect it's like sometimes I'll
watch our videos old and new and I'm
like if I if I'm like if I divorce
myself from that I'm watching myself
weird it's like what we do is I think
having developed in this Christian
bubble and then in this like other path
that is completely untrue ditional has
led to a certain type of we develop
certain comedic instincts with maybe
because we couldn't go to other things
I'll just give it as an example like if
we can't go to blue comedy then we tried
to push in other ways or I don't know I
I don't like to pick apart what we do
but I want to acknowledge that it's
weird and that it feels weird that our
instincts I rewatched the first episode
of the mythical show and I was like our
instincts in the way that we did this
the way that we talked at the top of
that episode about what it was and it
was a strange combination of like being
informed by what was starting to bubble
up on this thing called the Internet but
also all of our experiences in like we
were just when it came to live comedy we
were just as informed by like the
speakers who were the funniest at the
start of their Christian talks as we
were with any stand-up comedian you know
yeah and I don't even know how it all
shapes who we are but I do know that it
made us a weird brand of comedy because
yeah we we grew in this alternate kind
of like an alternate society like a
bubble if you can't be offensively you
can at least be confusing but no I I you
know enter wrap things up I think that
hopefully what we demonstrated in
telling this story just like link was
saying it's like
so much of the way that we are in the
way that our work is the stuff that we
create is characterized by this very
atypical journey that started with sort
of the first audience that we ever had
you know
officially as when we started our band
until we decided to start making YouTube
videos and you might also appreciate why
we've never answered the question in an
interview with well we quit college we
raised support to do a ministry that was
like training students and then we tried
a couple other things and then like you
know yeah we don't tell that story
because you can't just tell that story
in a sentence it's easier to just say
yeah we got engineering degrees did that
for a while and then we became youtubers
but hopefully and also as maybe there's
a lot of questions that are popping up
because of our association with and
being in full-time Christian ministry it
said like again use hash tag your
biscuits let us know I think it's it
whatever your your take on those things
are you might start to so what what is
rent links intersection with my take on
evangelical Christianity I think over
the next two weeks when we share our our
personal journeys will answer a lot of
those questions but log that stuff
hashtag your biscuits let us know
communicate amongst yourselves
but and we'll get to it yeah and you
know I would also ask you that I think
that this series were calling it I was
talking about this stuff both telling
the story the back story the last years
that we've done in the past two but then
also telling our personal stories I know
that there's a there's a certain cross
section of the audience out there that
is probably not interested in this and
it's like this isn't
thing I don't relate so I'm gonna tune
out but I know that there is a lot of
people who are like this kind of is my
thing this is my story or I there's a
lot of points where I can relate maybe
you know someone who can relate to this
who has a similar background we just
encourage you to share it with them I
think that this could also be the kind
of thing there there are probably a
certain number of people not a small
number who have kind of over the years
as they have sensed sort of a change
take place in US and they kind of see
that through the way we talk or they see
that in our work have had just
speculated about what's going on with us
maybe they've tuned out maybe they've
said I'm not going to be a part of this
new rhett and Link whatever whatever it
is this might be something that you want
to share with them as well so they could
kind of at least just understand some of
the context so thanks for doing that
yeah thanks for doing that
should I not give a wreck am I out of
principle I'm gonna give my rack okay
give her a wreck babe a wreck not
related to anything I just watched it
and it was a great movie I recommend
watching honey boy
Shia LaBeouf plays his own father and
it's the it almost feels like a
documentary of his relationship
tumultuous relationship with his father
as a child actor and it is it was it was
it was it was tough to watch I mean so
if you've got issues with your parents
or some way and maybe it's not for you
but it was it was extremely well acted
and it's like very very compelling
heartbreaking in a lot of ways but I do
recommend it honey boy honey boy it
hashtag ear biscuits next week we'll get
into the personal spiritual stuff it's
gonna get real real to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best